today's one minute monday is combine
your passions whatever business you're
in there's a lot of competition and
there's not much it separates you from
everybody else the way to stand out is
to combine your passion so that you're
the only one in your industry who does
what you do so say you love photography
and you love bowling and you may think
these things have nothing to do with
each other if you just try to become a
photographer you're up against every
other photographer there's nothing
special that makes you different there's
tons of people who do what you do what
you want to do is become the
photographer for bowlers and you might
think that sounds crazy but that's a
business bowlers need photographers and
you're going to start working with ideal
clients you're going to get paid more if
you're going to be the person to go to
you're going to get more referrals
because you are combining your passions
if you want to stand out if you want to
grow your business if you're struggling
to beat your competition the way to do
it is to combine your passions you'll
have more fun you'll make more money
you'll be a lot more successful believe